What do you think of consuming apricot seeds?
So apricot seeds are a way to get B-17.
The pros and cons of taking apricot seeds,
the pros is you're getting it as a whole food product
because you're getting the B-17 and the B-15 that
is in the apricot seeds as a quote unquote therapy.
The negative is that they taste horrible
and you really have to eat like 30 of them
to get the dose that's going to be really helpful for cancer.
Now, I don't remember your cheek swab test
and what came up on your cheek swab test.
But again, I test for B-17 and if that didn't come up,
I don't know that again, it's the same thing.
I mean, you could take a zillion things.
So if that's what you're being led to do,
then I'm not telling you not to, but you don't want
to be overwhelmed in your body.
Also, remember that B-17, you have to keep an eye on your liver
markers if you're going to be taking B-17.
So we've got to keep an eye on that.
And if you're taking apricot seeds that
call it falls into that category, all I ask you
is if anybody, I put this out to everybody,
not just the person asking this question.
If you're taking things beyond what I recommended
on your cheek swab, you're going to do it.
God's lady, you do.
But by all means, can you please let me know
so that we can get it in your file?
Because I don't want to like,
recheck your cheek swab in two months
and ask you, can you send me a list of everything
you're taking and then you send me a list
that just happened a couple of months ago.
The person I haven't heard from for over a year
and I asked them to send me a list of what they're taking.
And they're taking several things
that a cancer patient should not be taking.
It can cause a cancer to grow.
So please just let me know.
God let me to take this and I feel led to take this.
And if it's a good thing for cancer like apricot seeds,
you might not hear from me.
But if you say, God just led me to take these
methylated vitamins and because my sister said
it's really helped her with her anxiety.
So I started taking these.
Okay, I'm going to reach out to you and say,
I don't think that's a good idea.
And I'll give you the reason.
So it's just let me know so you're not taking something
that I don't think you should take.
So the caveat with apricot seeds,
if you're going to take apricot seeds
and you feel led to take those apricot seeds,
we've got to make sure we're checking
your comprehensive metabolic panel
because it can affect your AST, ALT, and alkaline phosphates.